we don't see you slowing down in the UK
demand so customers seems to like our
offering customer seems to recognize
that we are really putting everything
into our work to make the best holiday
they can have are you too concerned
about the strength of consumer spending
in the UK now that wages are starting to
lag inflation again my experience tells
me is that if there is a slowdown in
consumer confidence consumer are the
least or at last saving with their
holidays they want to go for holidays
and we feel well prepared because our
offering with our customer focus we feel
we feel good is it fair to say in all of
the markets in which you operates the UK
is probably the most competitive right
now right now yes
last year it was Germany this year it
seems to be UK but that is down to the
fact that we have really a lot of more
planes in the UK market and they are
flying all of them are most of them are
flying more to Spain and in Spain we
have the situation that we have as well
an increase in the hotel costs so that
is quite a competitive situation and
what we do with that situation is that
we are just focusing on a high quality
offering in Spain as well and we manage
it and what's also striking in your
statement though is that you say Turkey
and Egypt's are coming back as well I
mean presumably this is of a very low
base yes Egypt definitely Egypt is so
far away from the base we had before the
Arabian Spring but compared to last year
it's coming really strongly back in the
recent weeks and what we see in Turkey
is as well a bounce back a bounce back
after a very slow start in the into the
booking seasons we see now that
customers want to go they are attracted
by a value a good value for money
proposition it's a wonderful holiday
destination and has really great hotels
nice people and the people are coming
back one of the blemishes in this
results I guess is that losses are up in
your airline it is is this just because
of the over capacity in the airline
market now we had a very very difficult
his contour in our German market last
year and reflect at the end of the of
last year we said we have to turn around
Condor but it is what all what we are
doing is paying off in the second half
of the year so the first quarter was
still difficult it is a difficult
environment for contour and as well for
our UK airline but we see now already in
the second court that we are coming
really up and in the third and fourth
quarter we are convinced that we managed
to turn around in condom during the next
few months you're going to take full
control of your joint venture for High
Street travel agents with the coop it's
a really a place for travel agents in
this day and age I mean is this not a
business it's just being destroyed by
the internet we see a massive shift from
High Street to the web and we we have so
far we have it's well again 15% increase
on our websites however we are convinced
that there is a place for us on the Main
Street on the high street and we want to
stay on the high street
but we don't want to have our
unprofitable stock shops on the high
street that's why we are closing shops
if they are not profitable anymore and
where we see we have a shop next door or
close to the shop we are going to close
and then we try everything to transfer
our colleagues in the shops into the
other shop and try to keep the custom
but I would target this we want to have
as much direct contact with our customer
we want to be in contact with our
customer wherever he is looking for us
and that is still on the high street as
well